Hi zusammen!
Heute ist der World Vegan Day und daher habe ich mir folgendes überlegt:
Wir machen jetzt ein veganes Rezept.
Und da ihr gerne mehr herzhafte Rezepte von mir sehen möchtet, gibt's heute eine Pizza!
Und dafür mache ich jetzt einen leckeren Pizzateig - natürlich vegan!
Dafür fangen wir jetzt an und verrühren die Hefe mit lauwarmem Wasser, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich schon.
Und da gebe ich auch noch Zucker dazu. Das hilft einfach, dass die Hefe dann ein bisschen schneller aktiviert wird sage ich mal.
Das ist so ein Nährstoff für die Hefe.
Und jetzt weiß ich gerade nicht: Was war nochmal Zucker und was war Salz?
Ich probier' jetzt einfach.
*angewidertes Geräusch* Okay, das war Salz!
(H: Salz!)
Jetzt kurz verrühren und dann zugedeckt 5min stehen lassen und dann geht's auch schon weiter!
So, anschließend Mehl und Salz hinzufügen. dann erst in der Schüssel mit den Händen kneten
und anschließend auf der Arbeitsfläche 4-5min lang weiterkneten.
Und jetzt habt ihr einen sehr sehr geschmeidigen Teig, der nicht mehr an den Händen klebt.
Das Rezept ist ja für 2 Portionen ausgelegt, daher teile ich den jetzt schon durch 2.
Ihr könnt übrigens alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in der Videobeschreibung nachlesen.
So einmal durchteilen, dann zu Kügelchen formen
und dann lasse ich sie separat in 2 Schüsseln gehen für ca. 45-60min.
So, währen der Pizzateig geht, kümmern wir uns um die leckere Tomatensoße.
Die ist auch sehr sehr schnell hergestellt! Und zwar habe ich hier passierte Tomaten,
frischer Basilikum, Salz und Pfeffer. Und das Ganze werde ich jetzt ganz einfach miteinander pürieren.
So ihr Lieben, gleich geht's an's Belegen unserer Pizza! Ich hab' hier ein bisschen Gemüse kleingeschnibbelt
Ich hab' hier rote Zwiebeln, bunte Paprika und Mais - mag ich immer sehr, sehr gerne!
Und außerdem habe ich von Like Meat Like Grilled Chicken.
Das ist komplett vegan. Es ist aus Soja und alle Produkte von Like Meat sind vegan und glutenfrei.
Und ich habe es natürlich vorab einmal probiert. Ich hab's mir zubereitet und ich muss sagen, es hat uns sehr, sehr gut geschmeckt.
Ich glaub, auch dir hat's sehr gut geschmeckt!
(H: Ja, ausnahmsweise!)
Hamza war auch begeistert! Ich muss sagen wir sind immer vorsichtig bei veganen Produkten
und testen lieber vorher bevor ich das in einem Youtube-Video integriere und Like Meat hat mich geschmacklich echt überzeugt.
Vor allem ist es auch vegewürzt und sie haben's auch wirklich super, super lecker gewürzt sodass ich anschließend gar nichts hinzufügen muss!
Ich bereite das jetzt vor indem ich hier eine Pfanne mit etwas Kokosöl erhitze
und dann brate ich die so ca. 4min lang an und dann geht's auch schon an unsere Pizza!
So und als Nächstes nehmen wir uns den Pizzateig auf die bemehlte Arbeitsfläche und breiten ihn mit den Händen aus.
Ich nehme jetzt hier mein Pizzablech und den Pizzateig habe ich auf ca. 26cm ausgebreitet.
Bitte keinen Teigroller benutzen, das ist nicht so förderlich für den Teig.
Und ich mag ja diesen sehr, sehr dünnen Teig wie beim Italiener.
Und da gebe ich jetzt einfach die Soße, die Tomatensoße oben drauf
verstreich's mit 'nem Löffel und dann kommen die ganzen Beläge obendrüber.
So, fertig belegt. Und die sieht richtig, richtig lecker aus - schaut!
Und das gebe ich jetzt in den Backofen. Ganz, ganz wichtig ist die Einstellung: Ihr müsst das unbedingt vorheizen!
Maximale Temperatur! Meine maximale Temperatur sind 300° C.
Wenn ihr nur 280 habt: auch in Ordnung, dann braucht's vielleicht 1min länger.
Und bei mir sind die Pizzen immer nach 6-7min fertig. Bis gleich!
So, ich lasse mir die Pizza jetzt schmecken. Natürlich mache ich auch für euch den Geschmackstest nochmal!
Mmmh!
Ich hab' zum Schluss noch ein bisschen Olivenöl drübergeträufelt und für mich ist die Pizza perfekt.
Ich vermisse tatsächlich gar keinen Käse, ich vermisse kein Fleisch.
Und um den Geschmack von Like Grilled Chicken jetzt so ein bisschen zu beschreiben:
Also es kommt im ersten Bissen sehr nah ran an richtiges Fleisch
und im Nachgang merkt man natürlich, dass das nicht Fleisch ist aber es fehlt einem nichts weil das einfach so lecker gewürzt ist!
Und toll finde ich halt, dass ich auch nichts mehr nachwürzen musste, nichts einlegen musste extra.
Ultra lecker, macht's unbedingt nach! Ich schreibe euch wie gesagt alles Wichtige hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Hinterlasst diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben und falls ihr mehr vegane Rezepte sehen möchtet - vielleicht auch mal was Süßes -
dann schreibt's mir unbedingt unten in die Kommentare.
Und ansonsten würde ich sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!